got the world by the tail but a bumper
we got the world by the tail come I
would be like we got the world by the
tail
alrighty also we are here in Florida
we're going to this town which just some
mermaids it's a Murr time I just check
out some mermaids and just be a mermaid
you know just living that unlimited life
just doing big things not that long ago
I was dealing with an addiction and I
was completely limiting who I could be
as person there was choosing alcohol
over being present and now I'm here at
will keep watching and it's amazing
oh hi all know I paint some mermaids and
I feel pretty safe somebody wears this
underwater - yeah
that's scary I'm already afraid of the
water and so I had to wear this and the
water Gillick I'm singing dad this is
what every gave way dreams okay we're
gonna have to go bigger it's all in the
motion of the ocean you know what I mean
oh I know what you need we were mermaids
back way in the day when we were 19 20
years old and now we came back we came
back together in 1997 for the 50th
anniversary of wiki watches existence
the house it affected with the recipe by
paper be forever young you're forever
young saying that it's in the water
the weather is a lot of things in the
water that we cannot blame and so as we
were so close life itself
lately the river contains whirlpools of
rocky brothers as well as deep pools of
peace and tranquility cool and
refreshing work and ease hearts to
memories no matter what is going on in
our service site the Marines not the
flowing waters in the Austrian accent
bodies and their spirits
good lord this is scary I don't even
know when to stop
[Music]
well y'all you guys helped me conquer
two of my fears just like putting this
bran give it to the water this has been
so a lot of fun and I really I really do
thank you guys so much like this is such
a big deal for me to be here in this
moment wearing it
I'm hitting my first year of sobriety
and so just being here is so profound
for me feel like a year ago I was losing
my friends and family and possibly my
job hanging out with some mermaids like
a year later like it just kind of shows
that like your life is completely
unlimited you can be anywhere in a year
and be in Florida hanging out with some
[ __ ] mermaid